many species of lizards have mastered
the art of escape
fractures on their vertebrae allow them
to detach along multiple points of their
tails
with cracks in their bones one would
expect them to lose their tails often
yet unless they're in danger most
species tails stay faithfully attached
and when their tails do detach some
lizards can grow them back
after all the tail is an important organ
helping them move and balance with ease
inspired by the lizards crawling around
their desert campus researchers at nyu
abu dhabi set out to understand how
lizard tales achieve the goldilocks
principle a tail that isn't attached too
firmly or weakly but stays on just right
using a scanning electron microscope the
scientists took a closer look at the
plug and socket of muscles surrounding
fractures on the lizard's vertebrae
a previous study discovered that these
plugs were made up of smaller pillars
this time the researchers imaged the
interior of the sockets they expected
them to contain grooves that the
micropillars inserted into to create a
strong interlocking bond
instead they found that the sockets were
mostly smooth
speckled with faint imprints of the
micro pillars tops this meant the muscle
plugs were merely touching the socket's
surface
they also found many small holes on the
top of these pillars and suspected that
these nano pores were key to keeping the
tail attached to test this they used
silicone patches and glass to make a
lizard tail model
they created two types of patches with
and without nano pores
one set contained short micro pillars
while the other had taller micro pillars
similar to what is seen in lizards
the scientists pulled the patches apart
from the glass and found that the longer
pillars with nanopores were the hardest
to pry apart
in real life body fluids fill the nano
pores and micro pillars in a lizard's
tail
to mimic this the researchers added
water to the silicone patches they found
that this made the patches adhere more
strongly to the glass
models revealed that the small cracks
between the micro pillars and sockets
caused by the nano pores
slowed down new cracks that developed in
the tail
with all these strong connections how do
lizards drop their tails
the researchers captured three different
species of lizards and used a high-speed
camera to film the moment their tails
detached from their bodies when they
pulled at the tail or squeezed it the
lizard tail stayed firmly attached
but when grasped by the far end of their
tail the lizard was able to bend
triggering a fracture that allowed them
to peel their tails off their bodies and
run away
while two species they tested had an
easy escape
one species had to twist and turn in
order to release from its predator's
grasp using their lizard tail model the
scientists found that peeling patches
off was far easier than pulling them off
they also used a virtual model to
understand how a lizard's muscles might
help them detach their tails
they found that if less stress was
applied to the patches a scenario
similar to a lizard contracting its
muscles it was easier to peel the
patches off the glass they hope the
mechanisms behind this balancing act can
inspire new products such as bandages in
the mouth where chemical adhesives
wouldn't work as well
sometimes it takes a gross encounter to
inspire the most creative solution to
our problems
[Music]